maintenant car à morgane il va falloir
vous confesser interview c'est le mot
est très juste qu'on fait si clara
morgane avez vous déjà pêché par penser
par action ou par omission par les trois
à parler avez-vous commis le péché
d'adultère
une fois on choque ça il faudra voir une
petite chérie des mariés oui il faudrait
quand même petit pénitence pour ça on en
parlera après on s'étonne du
confessionnal mais je mettrais bien une
petite pénitence mois pour avoir pêché
en turquie hans à caraman regarde aller
vous à gauche tu veux accomplir des
actes contre nature
non jamais car à morgane est ce que vous
avez dit des mots grossiers comme beat
ou couilles
quand une bonne sans reculer ce monde
tout ça pour la grosse mi-temps ça
d'accord
est-ce que vous avez déjà été excité par
un animateur de télévision jeux rien non
un acteur oui
ak morgan dexter audition
cad et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu